So you all remember, after the 2020 general election,
I couldn't walk the lent of myself
without being told that we didn't run enough candidates.
People stop me in the streets,
at matches, at concerts,
shouted it to me from car windows,
stop me in the supermarket.
I couldn't buy a slice pan without somebody saying it to me.
So to you all, I now present
Xinfain's record number of candidates
for the local and the European elections.
We're running our largest number of candidates
and we are standing in every single electoral area.
So this is,
this is a really big team effort.
And so I have asked a very big man from Johnny Goal
to act as campaign director.
That would be the Bails Pierce Doctrine.
My friends, we are the party of change.
Change that means a roof over your head,
a secure, affordable home.
Change that means being able to see a doctor when you're sick,
getting the right care in the right place at the right time.
A future where life is affordable,
where a job provides a decent living
and when you can retire at 65 with your pension.
Change that means safe communities,
strong communities, built from the grassroots up,
protected by resourcing. Ungarthor
she icon of fully
and by ambitiously investing in community development,
in youth work, in the amazing talent and potential of our young people.
Change means a government,
a society that has the backs of ordinary people.
Friends, the Greatest failure of this government is in housing.
This is the most important local and European elections
for a generation. Because of housing.
Tens of thousands languishing on council housing lists.
Rip off friends. A whole generation locked out of home ownership
and record and growing homelessness.
Homes are out of reach because this government is out of touch.
And the inability to find an affordable home,
to lay down roots, to build a good life,
is driving so many young people out of Ireland
in search of opportunity abroad.
We say, enough of that.
It's now time to turn the tides.
We want, we need our young people here in Ireland,
our young people living abroad,
to have the opportunity to come back and pursue happiness at home.
We want our economy to thrive,
our society to blossom. Key to this is fixing housing.
And that means delivering
the biggest housing program in the history of the state.
So a vote for Shinfain in these elections
is the vote for affordable housing
to rent or buy.
A vote for Shinfain is the vote for more council housing.
A vote for Shinfain is the vote to end the housing crisis.
Shen Fein has the plan. Shen Fein has the man in Owen O Brin.
The government and the European Commission
may seek to dismantle Ireland's neutrality, but we will defend us.
Commission President Ursula Vanderline
showed her hand when she stood shoulder to shoulder with Israel
as they committed slaughter.
And war crimes against the people of Gaza.
She did not stand for us. She did not speak for us.
She never, ever will.
So it beggars belief that Fiona fall Infinity
Gail MEPS will line up to give her a second term in office. We will not.
We stand with the people of Palestine in their struggle for freedom,
for statehood, for peace,
for the end of apartheid and an end to the occupation.
That's who we are.
I was on the canvas. People are asking us,
when are you getting this loss out of government?
Yeah,
well, the truth is,
if you want change,
if you want to see the back of this failed government,
then you have to show up and you have to vote for us.
The first step is by voting for Shen Fein on June 7th.
Backing Shen Fein. We will work hard.
We won't let people down, because we're all in this together.
In the end,
these next six weeks really,
really matter. So keep your shoulders to the wheel.
Keep working hard in your communities and standing up for people.
Keep believing,
believing that we will achieve the Republic and the new Ireland.
So let's do this.
Let's leave us all on the pitch and on the dance floor.
Let's get the job done.
Let's deliver real change and a better future for everyone.